París acoge un nuevo movimiento a favor
de Ucrania bajo el lema en Solidaridad
con el pueblo ucraniano la comunidad
internacional está reunida en la capital
francesa con un doble objetivo
proporcionar ayuda inmediata a la
población y preparar la reconstrucción
del país tras las conferencias de lugano
Varsovia y Berlín esta nueva reunión
pretende neutralizar la estrategia
puesta en marcha por Rusia desde octubre
Rusia cuya debilidad militar ha quedado
de manifiesto ha optado por una cínica
estrategia de destrucción de las
infraestructuras civiles para destruir
Ucrania tras cada Victoria ucraniana en
el terreno Rusia reacciona cobardemente
con nuevos bombardeos de las
infraestructuras de distribución de
Electricidad gas O agua necesarias para
la supervivencia de la población durante
el invierno con el claro objetivo en
respuesta a las derrotas militares de
sembrar el terror entre la población
civil
los ponentes de la conferencia se
centrarán en cinco áreas clave energía
agua alimentos salud y Transporte pero
el esfuerzo principal será el de
restaurar la infraestructura después de
cada bombardeo ruso para que la
población pueda pasar el invierno y
finalmente aunque no hay alto el fuego
ni siquiera luces de un final de la
Guerra el segundo gran objetivo de la
conferencia será preparar la
reconstrucción del país en efecto el
trabajo de restauración que espera a
Ucrania llevará años sin mencionar el
inmenso coste que supondrá para el país